she's not breaking up with somebody for
a decade she sits around in it
i pretended like everything was okay it
was time for her to leave and she did
[Laughter]
i want to talk about your new podcast
because you really it really is
something where you are helping
people get where you are in a sense i
will talk to some of the most incredible
self-made business people in the world
i honestly entered into this and did not
realize
how much that's true the show
you know you have an idea about what a
show is going to be and then you get in
into it and it just crystallizes into
what it is and what it really is it's
all me
it's not about gossip it's not about who
who someone's dating or
you know anything nonsense it's all
about like how people
got to where they are their
non-traditional circuitous
route to success and these people are
all game changers they're all
visionaries you know geniuses
billionaires like
and that's the bar like i really i only
have people on that have really made a
mark
in this world and they're giving it all
they're really giving me everything so
there's
so much that people aren't getting
anywhere else is so great i can't even
tell you it's so much better than i
imagined it could be
i'm watching you all over the place
talking about the podcast
and i was like this is so bethany she
knows how to promote
she knows how to launch she knows how to
build a
business it's so you and so it seems
like you're putting your
your own kind of ideas to work and play
right now i i think it's what i'm meant
to do i prepare for it more than i've
ever prepared for anything i take it so
seriously
you're talking to maria shriver who's
spoken to whose uncle was jfk and who
was
interviewed president on air force one
i'm not coming in like an idiot you know
what i mean you have to know your stuff
and and and not waste their time and
people mark cuban's giving me an hour of
his time do you know how important time
is to someone so busy
so it's it's really good and i can't
believe they're trusting me
with their lives and their personal
stories and it's really good and there's
so many threads
that no matter how different people are
there are just certain tenets that they
all have that are in common which is why
they're successful so that's the way
that the audience is really gonna get it
you surprised fans by hanging out with
dorinda and people
loved it we have gotten really much
closer and it's better that we got
closer
not being on the show because it means
that it's not because of the show and
many friendships are forged because of
the show and then you get off and you
just
you just are not interested in being
friends with those people so she and i
we are
we are very good at advice for each
other life advice um i think she's a
great person we're working i'm working
on
projects with her you know i have a
production company so i i think she'd be
great for certain projects so
that's amazing and you know it's the
best thing that ever happened to her
that she was let go because she's sort
of blossoming and coming alive and she's
just not
she calls me sink your battleship i make
a decision i leave
i want to do something i go she's not
like that she's not breaking up with
somebody for a decade
she sits around in it so she wouldn't
have left and she didn't even realize it
was time for her to leave
so for for this time it was time for her
to leave and she did
and uh she's really happy and it's she's
kind of
feeling herself right now which is great
by the way there's talk that kathy
hilton could join the housewives of
beverly hills what do you think of that
well you know i used to work for her i
used to be paris and mickey's nanny
she'd be great she'd be great she's
going to come in she's a matriarch she
runs the show
and you know that either works or it
doesn't she might learn a lot about
herself or she will actually run the
show
but she's got a lot of wisdom i mean
growing up knowing her and kyle and the
whole family
you know she's got a power and a
presence and kyle
uh you know used to really like need
advice from her and look up to her and
it was almost like a mother figure so
you know it'll be interesting because
you got to have a strong
character and a strong skin but i don't
know if she would do it i
i don't think that that's true actually
i don't think so i don't know i didn't
ask nikki this time and i wouldn't tell
you what nicki said now
but i feel like that has been going on
for years and nicki was like absolutely
not so
you know the world does turn and she
could have changed her mind but i don't
think so
did you see paris's documentary i feel
like the whole world thinks they know me
i'm so used to like playing a character
that it's like hard for me to like be
normal
no one really knows who i am beyond she
was on my podcast you can't even know
how good she was in that documentary and
on my podcast her publicist we share a
publicist who said to me
it's the best interview she's ever done
it was amazing and
it was just so free and not canned and
she didn't know any of the questions and
we spoke for
an hour and she was just so revealing
and amazing and i was really proud of
her
you're going to talk about everything
from parenting to relationships
everything in this podcast what is the
one thing though that people
come fans ask you the most that you
think will be answered in this podcast
i just get things done so people ask me
how do you do it all
how do you balance it i'm very present
i'm very deliberate i'm very decisive
very decisive and by the way i know for
example
i know andy cohen really well i did not
realize how decisive he is until we
talked on our podcast because he's sort
of chilling and hanging out
and that was something i'm like oh wow
me too and i didn't realize that andy
cohen had to have
a job in high school like had to have a
job and i'm like oh wow
okay and mark cuban said to me something
that
another person who's like a mentor to me
said people who are not happy
are unhappy or unhappier when they make
money
people who are happy are happy er when
they make money
dana white who's the head of the ufc no
there's
there's no no and i'm the same he's like
there's no no don't tell me no
and i say i said my motto is a place of
yes so
i have something in common with all
these people and they have something in
common with each other so it's really
cool
what is something that you've learned
about successful people or or something
you see in successful people
that really make you see that why
they're different from everyone else
old school hard work what i grew up
knowing is hard work not like
a filtered instagram post giving your
card and schmoozing people and knowing
people or being
growing up going to the right schools
not going to harvard not any
you know what it is hard work you're not
above anything
you work your ass off you come from a
place of yes you get it done you figure
it out
hard work number one number two you know
you were you weren't hands at everything
from
most people most people or just for some
reason you just intuitively know
that you have to have a job like you
have to get on the road you can't keep
talking about it i also think that you
have to have an inner fire you never
stop
moving when do you take a breath i have
an inner fire
for sure but i do rest i value
i don't get it a lot but value sleep i
don't have a social life
i just like to be with my my my daughter
i like to be with my friends i like to
be in my pajamas and my dog
and i like to work and get things done
and that's just who i am
you have been posting a lot more with
brendan how she's growing up
is it weird what's how's that changing
your relationship
and how will it be as she grows up and
you know look teenagers do not want to
hang with their parents
at all so how will that be for you she's
not you know
super present in social media but once
in a while she like
jumps in the picture and wants to be
part of the program because you know
it's so much
about me and the public and um and she
likes dancing on tick tock
but i mean what they say is true you
just
need to value the time i spend every
waking moment
that i can with her i mean we are glued
to each other we're just quarantine
partners we are best friends
we just live for each other i just i
just i just devour her because it's just
i know that it it's got an expiration
date i hope it doesn't
and it'll be a different relationship
but it's just the best relationship you
could possibly have it's so
amazing hard to believe that it is 15
years ago that you made your first foray
into
um reality tv martha's apprentice mark
yes yes yes more and more i moved
through this process and in particular
this task
it's always me with a big idea what do
you remember about that
i remember that we got into that loft
and i felt like a racehorse that was
just
you know in the gate and it didn't
matter who anybody was it didn't matter
what background we came from it didn't
matter rich core
nobody just like here is the task go
get em and i remember you know finding
it hard to get my footing
and it being such a crazy intense
experience because it was not the
celebrity apprentice we were in lockdown
we were sequestered we had no phone no
paper and no newspapers no access
lights on we were an exposed room to
sleep i had to have a mask on
and we just i learned so much because i
just
realized that i was as good as i thought
i was i you don't know until you get
into
competino into a group with a bunch of
people am i just blowing flowers on my
skirt or am i really do i got it
and i thought on that show i just i i
hit my stride and i got it
you got it i can i can tell you you got
it at the end of the day
what do you want because you're doing so
many things but what do you
want i don't know i don't have any big
goals i never said i got to be a
billionaire i never said i need to be
anything i go with ideas that i like to
execute but i could go all the way with
this thing i mean i really we're hitting
our stride right now with my business
and i don't think there's any stopping
me and i felt this years ago
when my book naturally thing came out i
could feel you could people at home who
are
business people or want to be or
entrepreneurs you feel like a set of
waves coming in you feel like oh god
this is happening right now
it's happening right now and so i'm
enjoying that
and the rocket is flying and um you know
i'm ready i gotta stay on
so that's what's going on now and i just
want to be i love my time with my
daughter
i love being a great parent and being
together and laughing and snuggling and
just like loving her
i love executing my work dreams i love
building beautiful homes and just loving
them and love i'm very house proud
and um we'll just see where it all takes
us you know what i mean i love
i love being in a good strong
partnership relationship
so you know i'm just taking everything
day by day but really
it's good now really good
you